ja und für einen pandemie pakt hatte
schon im vergangenen jahr die damalige
bundeskanzlerin merkel auf dem
weltgesundheitstag geworben bei der g7
gesundheitsministerkonferenz heute und
morgen in berlin kommt das thema also
wieder auf den tisch so der plan des
gastgebers und der ist jetzt erstmal
unser gast einen schönen guten morgen
karl lauterbach der
bundesgesundheitsminister am morgen also
es soll ein pandemie packt geben welchen
wie sie es bereits angekündigt haben
wegweisende beschlüsse mit sich bringt
welche denn wir haben zunächst einmal
sehr lange daran gearbeitet die
g7-länder die minister aber auch
wissenschaftler haben zu gearbeitet und
die frage ist ja was muss konkret
gemacht werden konkret ist die situation
die das wir derzeit viele institutionen
haben die für pandemiefall so
beherrschung zuständig sind das ausbruch
nicht zu einer pandemie wird aber die
leute die das machen sollen die haben
wir zum teil nicht dafür muss eine
besondere ausbildung da sein und wir
machen uns gedanken darüber wie diese
ausbildung im süden der halbkugel der
südlichen halbkugel norden vorbereitet
werden kann dass es mehr leute gibt
überhaupt die technik beherrschen dann
müssen die balance system aufgebaut
werden das heißt dass man ausbrüche
sofort garantiert ist es ein
gefährlicher ausbruch oder nicht ist der
erreger gefährlich es muss bereitschaft
geben den up von ganz kurzer zeit wenn
ein neuer erreger da ist fachleute vor
ort zusammenzubringen so dass die
lokales infektionsgeschehen beherrschen
und es muss auch sehr schnell gelingen
impfstoffe und medikamente zu entwickeln
dafür braucht man auch vorberatungen
vorhaltung all das gehört in so einen
pakt hinein also schneller erkennen wenn
ich das jetzt richtig verstanden
aktuelle schneller reagieren das ist ja
auch ein gutes stichwort ich hatte eine
anmoderation schon gesagt die letzten
zwei jahre sind wir so ein bisschen in
diesem herbst reingestolpert und dann
hat man das gefühl man fängt wieder bei
null an es gab blog da uns das nicht gut
für die wirtschaft und für viele andere
bereiche ja auch nicht gut wie sind wir
jetzt vorbereitet was werden sie
unternehmen außer für 830 millionen euro
ein neu zugeschnittenen impfstoff zu
kaufen also was wie gehen wir in den
herbst wir gehen zunächst mal in den
herbst in dem die impfzentren schon
aufgebaut bleiben das heißt kommt eine
neue variante und wir müssen schnell
impfen dann können wir mit diesen
impfzentren und mit den niedergelassenen
kolleginnen und kollegen aber auch also
mit anderen also erst den ärzten
sarrazins weiter können wir sofort an
impfen und wir haben dafür drei
unterschiedliche impfstoffe so dass wir
fast jede variante richtigen impfstoff
ware neue auch für neue adaptierter
impfstoff wird jetzt produziert neben
stoff von der firma biotec und ein
kombinierter impfstoff haben und auch
nikon von der firma moderner so haben
wir haben wir einen hahn impfstoff
renault mégane eben stoff und mich
impfstoff und wir haben so viel dass wir
für jeden der sich impfen lassen will
oder die impf werden muss genug
impfstoff haben von dem stoff der der
beste ist und die impfzentren daten an
platz darüber hinaus also organisieren
wir es dass diejenigen die erkranken
sehr schnell behandelt werden können da
organisieren werden die kette wir
verbessern den datenfluss dass wir
früher die daten haben aus den
krankenhäusern wer ist eigentlich
infiziert wir wie viele betten sind
belegt und wir versuchen darüber hinaus
auch eine struktur aufzubauen dass wir
eine gute kampagne noch mal machen
können die zugeschnitten ist auf die
neuen verhältnisse und das
infektionsschutzgesetz wird auge
bearbeitet weil das ist ja jetzt so
überarbeitet worden dass selbst die
masken pflicht im innenraum nicht
möglich wäre ich glaube da brauchen wir
mehr darüber wird es auch debattiert
also nochmal weitere werkzeuge die man
vielleicht noch mal zurück in den kasten
legen wird also ich glaube da sind wir
uns alle einig prävention ist keine
hysterie sondern tatsächlich sehr
sinnvoll sie haben allerdings kürzlich
von einer möglichen ko wird killer
variante gewahrt warum dieses wie nicht
nur die union ist nennt eigentlich angst
schüren ohne wirklich belastbare belege
dafür ich habe keine angst geschürt
sondern ich habe versucht daher variante
ja der begriff also vielleicht nicht
optimal gewählt aber er hat es ja
zugespitzt sonst würden wir jetzt aber
wieso ihr aber warum zuspitzt weise
unsere ernsthaften es ist geschafft das
ist ja ernsthaft also ich muss die den
menschen die informationen geben viele
denken ja jetzt das virus wird immer
harmloser wir sind jetzt schon panik und
demnächst eine ganze hand erkältung das
wäre ich sogar oft also im fernsehen
aber sie glauben doch nicht bei killer
variante das dann leute die wirklich
auch alles ernst nehmen dann nicht auch
zurückschreckt aber ich sagen okay hat
jetzt aber ich würde so gerne darüber
sprechen was gemeint ist und deshalb das
wichtig ist und nicht um sehe also
überall so demographie inbegriffen wir
hatten uns so viel an der beeke gute auf
war das der richtige besitzstand der
minister am richtigen platz ist sehr
schnell genug die treppe hochgegangen b
noten aspekte auch gut geht darüber
reden aber die knappe zeit ist das ist
eben eine fehlannahme dass die menschen
glauben das virus wird immer haben lohse
wir haben derzeit also um die 140 150
tote pro tag schon mit der omicron
variante werden jetzt das virus sich
leicht verändert ginge in tiefere
abschnitte bliebe aber so ansteckend wie
es jetzt ist darauf habe ich abgehoben
dann hätten wir extreme ansteckung
möglichkeiten weil die varianten dann
über die vorhandenen impfungen zum teil
weg gehen würden wir hatten aber auch
schwere verläufe das kann kein
wissenschaftler derzeit ausschließen das
zeigt auch die literatur daher muss ich
auch auf diese möglichkeit hinweisen so
dass die menschen nicht zu wirklich
gefallen aber es wirkte natürlich ein
bisschen wie der blick in seine
glaskugel und das ist natürlich bei
diesen themen nicht besonders sinnvoll
sie haben daraus also in der nature
studie sind also zum beispiel jetzt die
möglichkeiten für den herbst also
relativ gut beschrieben worden ist nicht
die einzige oder wir haben jetzt eine
studie aus riesa gezeigt dass selbst
eine heftige mikrowelle die data
variante nicht komplett verschwindet
somit ist nicht die glaskugel das
nämlich für mich in anspruch dass ich
schon die wissenschaft berücksichtige
und auch mit dem expertenrat und wie
kann es eigentlich sagen habe es gerade
im beitrag auch gehört dass die
datenlage immer noch jetzt spitze ich
auch mal zu so katastrophal ist ja die
datenlage ist in einem punkt schlecht
wir bekommen die daten aus den
krankenhäusern nicht so schnell wie wir
sie benötigen daran arbeite ich derzeit
fieberhaft dass sich das ein bisschen
schnittstellen geschaffen werden zum
beispiel zwischen
krankenhausinformationssystemen die die
krankenhäuser haben und meldesysteme an
das robert koch institut
jetzt ist es aber so die
krankenhausinformationssysteme die die
krankenhäuser haben sind dafür die
vorbereitet worden es ist ein
wahnsinniger aufwand jetzt alle
krankenhäuser so umzurüsten dass die zb
ein system haben die mit den mädels
systemen vom beispielsweise den kleines
gesundheitsämtern oder robert
koch-institut kompatibel sind das heißt
das ist schnell gesagt dass es aber sehr
viel arbeit ich arbeite daran fieberhaft
aber es ist schwer das umzusetzen wir da
bekommen daten sind ja wahnsinnig
wichtig um auch zu wissen welche
maßnahmen wirklich ergriffen werden
sollten dann in zukunft und welche
wirklich auch gut funktioniert haben wir
haben es gerade von hendrik strikt
gehört es gibt eben diesen
sachverständigenausschuss an der sauer
die wirksamkeit der massnahmen
untersuchen ihn wird jetzt vorgeworfen
dass sie diesen evaluierungs auftrag
aufgeweicht hätten noch ein bisschen
weichzeichnen wollen nein das könnte ich
gar nicht der diese kommission die ich
nicht selbst einberufen habe und es auch
nicht unsere einzige kommission noch
nicht die wichtigste wir haben ja den
expertenrat der uns regelmässig bereit
aber diese kommission ist
zusammengesetzt worden von parlament und
von regierung das heißt ich kann selbst
den regierungsauftrag der damals
erstellt ist dann kann ich gar nicht
verändert dafür brauche ich die
zustimmung des parlaments und auch der
regierung und auf mich ist aber der
vorsitzende der kommission professor hus
dazugekommen gesagt wir können das
möglicherweise bis zum 30.06 nicht
schaffen ja das ist also anders
dargestellt als er strebt ja der einzige
noch verbleibende virologe in der
kommission ist und weil herr droste hat
die arbeit dort eingestellt und jetzt
ist die frage ob die arbeit der
kommission mit dem einen noch
verbleibenden virologen der kommission
herrn stieg selbst fertig werden kann
oder nicht er strickt sagt ja das ist
eine wichtige aussage aber er ist dann
auch derjenige der diese leistung
erbringt das muss man klar sehen oder ob
das nicht so ist aber es ist unstrittig
dass vier teile wo es nicht um geologie
geht und also sagen wir den maßnahmen
gegen die viren sondern wo es um richtig
dass wir kommen sowieso ich habe selbst
also gar keine aktien darin dass es
keine kommission die ich eingesetzt habe
ich kann mit jedem ergebnis leben und
ich habe das für richtig dass du denn
jetzt mal natürlichen die fraktion sagen
das soll zum 30 06 und kommen sehr gern
es ist wirklich nicht wert entscheidend
wir haben den expertenrat der uns fast
jede woche berät es geht ja auch nicht
um aktien sondern einfach um zu wissen
was dann auch zu tun ist und was sie
heute tun das wissen wir jetzt auch
nämlich mit den anderen g7
gesundheitsministern darüber zu beraten
wie man gemeinsam eine möglicherweise
nächste pandemie besser vorbereitet
entgegenblickt vielen dank herr
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach ich danke ihnen